الطائرات الحربيه المقاتلات الحربيه ضربت
هذه
المنطقه
بكل ثقلها
وبكل قوه
دمرت منطقتنا بشكل
كامل استهدفت
منازلنا دمرتها بشكل كامل لا
وجود
لحياه
في
نستمع واياكم الى القذيفه بالقرب من
المنطقه التي
دخلناها
قذيفه هنا بالقرب من المنطقه التي دخلتها
هي منطقه ال الوح هذه المنطقه الشمال
النصيرات بالقرب من يعني شارع صلاح
الدين وهذا الدمار
الكبير في منازلنا
هنا جوله في منطقه الدعوه شمال النصيرات
دمار كبير
وهائل من قبل طائرات الاحتلال ومدفعيه
الاحتلال والجرافات التي دخلت هذا الشارع
ودمرت كل
شيء هذه هي المنازل قد
دمرتها مقاتلات الاحتلال
الحربيه بشكل
كامل
وقصفت يعني هذه المنطقه هي منطقه خطره
جدا عمارات سكنيه هنا برج سكني تم تدميره
بشكل
كامل لربما هذه
المنطقه اصابها زلزال
قوي نعم نستمع الى الانفجارات
القويه هذا البرج السكني تم تدميره بشكل
كامل
هذه من طقه دمرت بشكل كامل منطقه الدعوه
شمال
النصيرات